a schoolgirl dragged down by her hair
and punched on the ground
we've protected identities but another
girl while filming gets involved kicking
her in the face
dozens of watching and videos an ambush
that everyone seemed to know was about
to happen just outside a school in
Rochdale
and the motive quite possibly the videos
themselves a moment of notoriety on
social media creating content to be
shared and laughed about in private
groups on Snapchat
courageously the 13 year old girl who
was attacked just before the Easter
holidays wants to speak about it she's
asked not to show her face
and how badly did they hurt you I had a
black eye
in my head every time I spoke her
um I couldn't laugh because my head hurt
I couldn't move my neck my back was sore
I have a scar on my knee that being
caught open
I don't really like walking around now
where I know people from my school are
going to be
because they are ever up pretty much
everyone in my school knows about it
yeah
I don't and I'm kind of glad I don't
have a form because I feel like I just
getting messaged about it all the time
because your phone got smashed when you
got attacked yeah they're stumped on it
so you think it's just random they just
pick a Target yeah they're easy target
someone who's normally quiet somebody
who doesn't bother anybody they'll then
use that person as a Target to create
this online so content yeah Billy the
half brother and legal guardian of the
girl who was attacked says this is
becoming a dangerous craze I don't
believe my sister has any long-running
rivalries within the school I believe
this was created solely for the content
of the internet so it was just a random
attack so that people could post it
online and show off of course that's
what it boils down to showing off um I'm
gonna Chad's gonna lose her life at this
careers and you think it is a craze it
is a crazy age it's happening all over
the country the national bullying
helpline told Sky News this is indeed an
escalating and deeply troubling National
Trend their Ambassador is actor Debbie
Arnold can you imagine it's a whole load
of people just suddenly went for you do
the children realize that this is a
criminal offense beating somebody up
it's not a game the police and the
schools have got to take more action
for safeguarding reasons we've decided
not to name the school in Rochdale near
where the attack happened but parents
tell us there have been several similar
attacks just at this one school here
inside the premises a girl secretly
starts recording we've reduced the audio
to protect identities but one says can
you see her then are we doing it or not
are we doing it outside or in here in
here another confirms Gorman Gorman says
another then follows a verbal assault
which leads up to a physical one
because these are posted in private
groups on Snapchat often the video
achieves notoriety within the school
without adults becoming aware
they've come over he's heard him say
let's get him another mother at the same
school who will call Jenny told us last
term her son was randomly attacked by
more than a dozen children on the
playing fields and she feels the school
is failing in its duty of care
from them kids coming into them gates at
8 20. they're there to safeguard our
children and they fail to do that
the school we're not naming told us it
takes its duty of care extremely
seriously with a high visibility
presence of Staff within the grounds and
the immediate vicinity and they respond
robustly to disclosures on student
safety the incidents we've highlighted
are subject to ongoing inquiries
Sky News understands the attack on this
13 year old is now being investigated by
the police but the national bullying
helpline says schools and authorities
are failing to keep Pace with this
growing uk-wide problem Jason Farrell
Sky News